In May of last year, about a month after the bombings at the Boston Marathon, there was this weird news story-- maybe you saw this-- about a guy in Florida who was shot by an FBI agent.
去年五月，波士顿马拉松爆炸案发生大约一个月后，出现了一则奇怪的新闻——也许你看到了——一名住在佛罗里达州的男子被FBI探员枪杀。
We're getting word this morning about a shooting in Orlando, Florida. It involves the FBI and a man who may have had ties to the Boston bombing suspects. Our senior correspondent--
我们今早接到消息，佛罗里达州奥兰多发生了一起枪击事件。事件涉及FBI和一名可能与波士顿爆炸案嫌疑人有牵连的男子。我们的资深记者——
The shooting victim was a Chechen guy named Ibragim Todashev, and he'd known one of the guys accused in the Boston bombing.
这名枪击案受害者是一名车臣裔男子，名叫易卜拉欣·托达舍夫（Ibragim Todashev），他认识波士顿爆炸案中被指控的一名男子。
Ibragim Todashev was a friend of the older brother in that case, Tamerlan Tsarnaev. He was in contact with Tamerlan Tsarnaev. He had been to Boston to visit him, and he was planning a trip--
易卜拉欣·托达舍夫是该案中哥哥塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫（Tamerlan Tsarnaev）的朋友。他与塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫有过联系。他曾去波士顿探望过他，并且正计划去——
Remember that Tamerlan Tsarnaev was the older brother in the Boston Marathon case. He's the one killed in a shootout in Watertown after that crazy car chase. He's usually portrayed as the more radical brother in news reports.
记住，塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫是波士顿马拉松案中的哥哥。他是在那场疯狂的汽车追逐战后，在沃特敦的交火中被击毙的那个人。在新闻报道中，他通常被描述为更激进的那个兄弟。
That's who the Florida guy was buddies with. And the Florida guy was shot in his own apartment by the FBI seven times during an interview they were doing with him. The FBI said almost nothing about this. But of course, there were leaks.
佛罗里达那名男子就是他的哥们儿。而佛罗里达那名男子在接受FBI审讯时，在自己的公寓里被FBI连开七枪打死。FBI对此几乎只字未提。但当然，还是有一些泄密消息传出。
And officials tell us that the man attacked the FBI agent, who then shot and killed him.
官员们告诉我们，该男子袭击了FBI探员，探员随后将其开枪击毙。
Some reports said that he came at the agent with a knife. Others said it was a pole. Others said a broomstick, maybe a sword.
有的报道说他拿着刀冲向探员。有的说是根棍子。还有的说是扫帚柄，甚至可能是把剑。
And the story was leaked to the press by law enforcement was that before the FBI shot this guy, Ibrahim Todashev, he confessed to something. He implicated himself and the alleged Boston bomber in a crime, a gruesome crime, a triple murder of three drug dealers who were killed gangland style in a Boston suburb two years earlier, long before the marathon bombings. According to the leaks, this guy in Florida was just about to write out a confession when he freaked out, attacked a federal agent, and they had to shoot him to death.
执法部门泄露给媒体的故事是：在FBI击毙易卜拉欣·托达舍夫之前，他供认了一些事情。他指认自己和所谓的波士顿爆炸案嫌疑人共同犯下了一桩罪行，一桩骇人听闻的罪行——两年前在波士顿郊区，也就是马拉松爆炸案发生前很久，有三名毒贩以黑帮手法被杀。根据泄密消息，这名身在佛罗里达的男子本打算写下供词，却突然发狂，袭击了一名联邦探员，导致他们不得不将他击毙。
Weird, right? The FBI kills somebody in his own home and then says, sure, we killed him. But, you know, he was a murderer. He confessed to it. OK, well, we don't have a recording or a signed confession, but believe us, he really did it.
很奇怪，对吧？FBI在他家里杀了一个人，然后说，没错，是我们杀了他。但是，你知道的，他是个杀人犯。他供认了。好吧，我们没有录音，也没有签署的供词，但请相信我们，他确实干了。
As one editorial put it in a suburban Massachusetts paper, quote, "When a key witness to a serious crime is killed during questioning, people deserve to know why." When prosecutors say he revealed a critical fact before he was killed, people expect proof. The father of Ibragim Todashev-- the guy the FBI killed in Florida-- held a press conference calling for answers, and he pointed out it was hard to understand why federal agents would need to actually kill his son. He spoke in Russian.
正如马萨诸塞州一家郊区报纸的社论所言：“当严重罪行的关键证人在审讯中被杀时，人们有权知道原因。”当检察官声称他在被杀前透露了关键事实时，人们期待证据。易卜拉欣·托达舍夫的父亲——也就是被FBI在佛罗里达击毙的那个人——举行了新闻发布会要求给出答案，他指出很难理解联邦探员为何非要杀掉他的儿子。他用俄语发言。
Even if he lost his temper and became violent, they could have restrained him or wounded him, shoot him in the leg or the arm or the shoulder. But what happened was murder. Maybe my son knew something the police didn't want to come out, and they killed him to keep him silent.
即使他发火并变得暴力，他们也可以制服他或者打伤他，朝他的腿、手臂或肩膀开枪。但发生的事是谋杀。也许我儿子知道一些警察不想让外界知道的事情，于是他们杀了他以求灭口。
Theories sprang up. On the more conspiracy-ish side of things, there had already been persistent rumors that the alleged Boston bomber, Tamerlan Tsarnaev, had been an FBI informant. Maybe this guy in Florida knew something about that and they wanted to shut him up. These theories were especially rife in Boston, where the FBI has colluded with its criminal informants in the past.
各种理论层出不穷。在阴谋论那一面，一直有传言称波士顿爆炸案嫌疑人塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫曾是FBI的线人。也许佛罗里达这名男子知道一些内情，而他们想让他闭嘴。这些理论在波士顿尤为盛行，因为那里曾发生过FBI与其线人勾结的丑闻。
At the very least, people wondered if the FBI was being so silent about the incident because it didn't want to admit its own blunders during the interrogation, blunders that led them to shoot a man seven times. The Boston Globe, Boston Herald, and dozens of other newspapers have called for an explanation of how and why this happened. The Washington Post declared, "The last thing the US government needs is to fuel wild conspiracy theories. The Obama administration must move heaven and earth to get to the bottom of what happened and make it public, quickly."
至少，人们怀疑FBI之所以对这起事件保持沉默，是因为不想承认在审讯过程中犯下的拙劣错误，正是这些错误导致他们向一个人连开了七枪。《波士顿环球报》、《波士顿先驱报》和数十家其他报纸都呼吁解释这件事发生的过程和原因。《华盛顿邮报》宣称：“美国政府最不需要的就是助长疯狂的阴谋论。奥巴马政府必须竭尽全力查明真相，并迅速向公众公布。”
And the FBI promised to clear the air. They promised an investigation into the shooting. That was last May. Since then, officials keep saying, essentially, it's coming, it's coming. Now it has been nine months, and still, nothing. Nine months.
FBI承诺会澄清事实。他们承诺对枪击事件展开调查。那是去年五月的事。从那以后，官员们一直在说，本质上就是，“调查快出来了，快出来了”。现在已经九个月了，仍然什么都没有。九个月了。
At this point, the mother of one of the men killed in that triple murder now agrees with the dad you heard-- the dad whose son supposedly committed the murder, murdered her son-- that things don't seem to add up. This mom, Bellie Hacker, wonders why would the FBI kill the one person who could shed light on who murdered her kid?
目前，那起三尸命案中一名遇害者的母亲现在也认同你们听到的那位父亲的说法——那位儿子的死被认为杀害了她儿子的父亲——事情似乎有些讲不通。这位母亲，贝莉·哈克（Bellie Hacker），想知道为什么FBI要杀掉唯一能揭开谁杀害她孩子真相的人？
I know there's some sort of a cover up somewhere. I don't know what it is, and I don't have any theories about it. But it's too strange.
我知道某个地方肯定有掩盖真相的行为。我不知道具体是什么，我也没有任何理论。但这一切太奇怪了。
A full and swift release of information would clear the air about that.
全面且迅速地发布信息会澄清对此事的疑虑。
Massachusetts congressman Bill Keating sits on the Homeland Security committee, and he says that in general, when it comes to anything related to the Boston bombing, the FBI is peculiarly unforthcoming, much worse than any other law enforcement agencies when giving out information. And he says investigations into police shootings just do not have to take this long. He knows this because he's been involved with them himself back when he was a district attorney.
马萨诸塞州众议员比尔·基廷（Bill Keating）是国土安全委员会成员，他表示，总体而言，凡是与波士顿爆炸案相关的任何事情，FBI都异常地不配合，在提供信息方面远比其他执法机构差劲。他还表示，对警察枪击事件的调查根本不需要耗费这么长时间。他对此很清楚，因为他曾担任过地方检察官，亲自参与过此类调查。
I think the longest one we were involved in was maybe two months.
我想我们参与过的最长的调查可能也就两个月。
Versus this case.
相比于此案。
In this instance, there was a crime scene that amounted to a room and just a few individuals, so it's something that should have taken short order. And even though there's an extensive report making vetting that goes on, that delay now continues eight or nine months later. And that is puzzling.
在这种情况下，犯罪现场不过是一个房间和几个人，所以这应该很快就能解决。尽管有广泛的报告审查流程，但这种延误在八九个月后仍在继续。这很令人困惑。
From the outside, it just makes it look so suspicious. Do you know what I mean?
从外部看，这显得非常可疑。你明白我的意思吗？
Well, that's what happens when, you know, delays occur.
嗯，你知道，当延误发生时，情况就是这样。
Today on our program, we dive into this mystery. There's a triple murder in Massachusetts linked to the alleged Boston bomber and this other guy in Florida. Both of those men are dead-- the one in Florida in circumstances that are still very unclear. And as you'll hear, the deeper that we dug into these questions, the weirder the story got.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将深入探讨这个谜团。马萨诸塞州发生了一起涉及所谓波士顿爆炸案嫌疑人和佛罗里达那名男子的三尸命案。这两个人都死了——佛罗里达那一个死时的情形依然非常不清楚。正如你将会听到的，我们对这些问题挖掘得越深，故事就变得越奇怪。
The police and FBI were doing all kinds of things that just did not seem to make much sense. We're going to bring you the facts that we've been able to find. We're going to tell you the ones that we could not find, and then at the end of the hour, our best guess as to what we think might have happened. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
警察和FBI做的所有事情似乎都毫无道理。我们将向你提供我们所能发现的事实。我们也会告诉你那些我们无法发现的信息，然后在节目结束时，我们将给出我们对可能发生的事情的最佳猜测。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Well, Susan Zalkind is a reporter who lives in Boston, and she has spent the last six months looking into all this for Boston magazine and for us, and also for herself. She has a personal connection to what happened, this triple murder, the one that the guy in Florida supposedly is connected to.
苏珊·扎尔金德（Susan Zalkind）是一位住在波士顿的记者，过去六个月她一直在为《波士顿》杂志、为我们，也为了她自己调查这一切。她与这件事——那起佛罗里达男子据称与之有关的三尸命案——有着私人联系。
Her connection is that she was friends with one of the victims in that original crime-- one of the three drug dealers who was killed, Eric Weissman. So here's Susan.
她的联系是，她是那起原始罪案的受害者之一的朋友——那三名被杀毒贩之一，埃里克·韦斯曼（Eric Weissman）。下面请听苏珊的讲述。
I met Eric five years before he was killed. It was the summer after my freshman year in college. I was 19 and he was 26, and we hung out a few times that summer, usually driving around aimlessly in his car, listening to music, talking, and smoking pot. He had wire-rimmed nerd glasses and a Jewfro, and honestly, he was just really sweet. He sold high-end weed, flew to Amsterdam regularly for special seeds, and talked about selling pot as if it were a community service.
我在埃里克被杀前五年认识了他。那是大学一年级后的夏天。我19岁，他26岁，那个夏天我们经常聚在一起，通常是漫无目的地开车兜风、听音乐、聊天、抽大麻。他戴着细框眼镜，留着犹太式蓬松卷发，老实说，他真的很贴心。他卖高档大麻，经常飞往阿姆斯特丹买特殊种子，谈起卖大麻时就好像是在从事社区服务一样。
Over time, I stopped smoking weed. We grew apart. The last time I spoke to him was eight months before he was killed.
随着时间推移，我不再抽大麻了。我们渐行渐远。我最后一次和他说话是在他被杀前八个月。
My dad's a criminal defense attorney, and Eric wanted his number to hire him. Police had raided his apartment. A few years earlier, he told me he only sold pot, but police also seized coke and OxyContin. He sounded scared. I told him it would be OK.
我父亲是刑事辩护律师，埃里克想拿到他的电话号码以便聘请他。警察突袭了他的公寓。几年前他告诉我他只卖大麻，但警察还搜出了可卡因和奥施康定。他听起来很害怕。我告诉他会没事的。
Approximately 2:30 PM today, the Waltham police responded to this scene, a-- sorry-- very graphic crime scene. There are three dead bodies in the apartment. This is a fluid, ongoing investigation.
今天下午大约2点30分，沃尔瑟姆（Waltham）警方赶到了这个现场，一个……抱歉……非常血腥的犯罪现场。公寓里有三具尸体。这是一个流动的、正在进行的调查。
The day Eric's body was discovered, Middlesex County District Attorney Gerry Leone faced a scrum of reporters outside the crime scene in Waltham, a suburb of Boston. Leone said he couldn't release many details, not before they got in touch with the victims' families. He wouldn't even confirm the victims' genders or their approximate ages. There wasn't a lot of information, except for this, which seemed very specific.
埃里克的尸体被发现的那天，米德尔塞克斯县地方检察官格里·利昂（Gerry Leone）在沃尔瑟姆——波士顿的一个郊区——的犯罪现场外面对一大群记者。利昂说他不能透露太多细节，在联系上受害者家属之前不能透露。他甚至不愿确认受害者的性别或大概年龄。除了这一点看起来非常具体的信息外，没有太多其他消息。
It does look like the assailants and the decedents did know each other. We have no evidence of a break in the apartment, and we have other indicia that the decedents and the assailants were known to each other.
看起来袭击者和死者确实互相认识。我们没有发现公寓有被强行闯入的迹象，还有其他迹象表明死者和袭击者相互认识。
You're saying assailants, plural. You mean you're thinking that more than one person is responsible?
你说的是“袭击者”，复数。你是说你认为不止一个人对此负责？
We're not sure at this time. We know there were at least two people who are not in that apartment now who were there earlier.
目前我们还不确定。我们知道至少有两个人曾在那间公寓，但现在已不在那里了。
It was later revealed that the killers slit their throats. The three bodies lay face down, heads turned to the side, each in a neat pool of blood. Two of the bodies had about a pound and a half of marijuana dumped on them. The scene didn't scan like a robbery.
后来披露，杀手割断了他们的喉咙。三具尸体面部朝下，头部转向一侧，每一具都躺在整齐的血泊中。其中两具尸体上被倾倒了大约一磅半的大麻。现场看起来不像抢劫。
There were eight and a half pounds of pot left in bags and glass jars and $5,000 lying next to the bodies. They were killed sometime after 7:30 on the night of September 11, 2011.
现场留下了八磅半装在袋子和玻璃罐里的大麻，还有5000美元现金散落在尸体旁边。他们是在2011年9月11日晚上7点30分之后被杀的。
Weeks passed, and months. My friends and I would convene nightly meetings huddled in our apartments and run through all the possibilities of who could have killed our friend. But there didn't seem to be any leads, and certainly no arrests. I didn't hear much more about the case, really, until a year and a half later, after the Boston Marathon bombings, when news reports said police and FBI were beginning to look into the connection between the alleged bomber, Tamerlan Tsarnaev, and the Waltham murders.
几周、几个月过去了。我和朋友们每晚都会聚在我们公寓里，讨论谁可能杀了我们的朋友。但似乎没有任何线索，当然也没有人被捕。我确实没有听到关于这个案子的更多消息，直到一年半后，在波士顿马拉松爆炸案发生之后，新闻报道称警方和FBI开始调查所谓爆炸案嫌疑人塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫与沃尔瑟姆谋杀案之间的联系。
Tamerlan had been close friends with one of the three murder victims, a guy named Brendan Mess. But after the murders, Tamerlan had acted suspiciously, Didn't go to Brendan's funeral.
塔梅尔兰曾与三名受害者之一的布伦丹·梅斯（Brendan Mess）是密友。但谋杀案发生后，塔梅尔兰表现得很可疑，他没去参加布伦丹的葬礼。
I talked to one guy who said he went up to Tamerlan to offer his condolences about Brendan, and Tamerlan literally laughed it off. People actually told investigators to look into Tamerlan Tsarnaev back in 2011, right after the murders, but police never followed up. After the marathon bombings, there were rumblings of a scandal about all this. If police had questioned Tamerlan back in 2011, is it possible he'd be in prison instead of placing two homemade bombs at the finish line?
我和一个家伙谈过，他说他曾走近塔梅尔兰对他表示对布伦丹的哀悼，结果塔梅尔兰竟然当众大笑。实际上在2011年谋杀案刚发生后，就有人告诉调查人员去调查塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫，但警方从未跟进。马拉松爆炸案后，关于这一切的丑闻传言四起。如果警察在2011年就审问了塔梅尔兰，他是否可能已经待在监狱里，而不是在终点线放置了两枚自制炸弹？
But then pretty quickly came the same news reports you heard at the beginning of the show, that some guy in Florida named Ibragim Todashev supposedly admitted that he'd been involved in the Waltham murders, and that Tamerlan had been with him. There was no written confession. There was no reporting. And then Todashev was shot by an FBI agent.
但随后很快就出现了你们在节目开始时听到的同样的新闻报道，称佛罗里达一个名叫易卜拉欣·托达舍夫的家伙据称承认自己参与了沃尔瑟姆谋杀案，而且塔梅尔兰当时也在场。没有书面供词。没有报道细节。然后托达舍夫就被FBI探员枪杀了。
I had no idea what to make of it. A year and a half had gone by with no news at all, and now, suddenly, they had found the killers, and both of them are dead? Should I really believe that these two guys murdered my friend?
我不知道该怎么理解这一切。一年半过去了，一点消息都没有，现在突然间他们找到了杀手，而且这两个人都死了？我真的应该相信这两个人谋杀了我的朋友吗？
So I start to look into everything I could learn about the guy in Florida, Ibragim Todashev. I talked to anyone I could reach who knew him-- friends, family, former coworkers-- and asked them all what kind of guy Ibragim Todashev was. But it seemed like he was a hard person to get a read on.
所以我开始调查关于佛罗里达那个叫易卜拉欣·托达舍夫的人所能了解的一切。我联系了所有能联系到的认识他的人——朋友、家人、前同事——询问他们易卜拉欣·托达舍夫是什么样的人。但看起来他很难让人摸透。
Well, OK, the one thing I noticed about him, he never smiled in his pictures or anything like that.
嗯，好吧，关于他我注意到的唯一一件事是，他在照片里从来不笑，或其他类似的情况。
I used to see him at the mosque. He was a good guy, nice guy. Like, you know, doing his prayers, and all that.
我以前在清真寺见过他。他是个好人，很好的人。就像，你知道，做祷告之类的。
Ibragim-- I never liked that dude. I'm gonna be honest. He was, like, a douchebag.
易卜拉欣——我从来不喜欢那家伙。我要说实话。他就像个混蛋。
To be honest, this guy seems like he had a temper.
老实说，这家伙似乎脾气很暴躁。
He was-- I can't speak how he was with somebody else, but with me, he was grateful, thoughtful husband.
他是——我不确定他跟别人是怎么相处的，但对我来说，他是个懂得感恩、体贴的丈夫。
He was actually, if you get to know him, he was a pretty good guy.
其实，如果你了解他，他是个相当不错的人。
I learned Ibragim was religious and prayed regularly, but he also went to clubs and hit on women. He liked to hang out with a close-knit group of Chechen friends, and he was a fighter. He trained seriously in mixed martial arts, a sport where boxing, wrestling, kickboxing and jujitsu are all mixed together. He wanted to go pro.
我了解到易卜拉欣很虔诚，经常祷告，但他也会去夜店搭讪女性。他喜欢和一群关系紧密的车臣朋友待在一起，而且他是个格斗选手。他曾认真地训练综合格斗，这是一种拳击、摔跤、自由搏击和柔术混合在一起的运动。他想成为职业选手。
He'd emigrated from Chechnya to Boston in 2008, lived there for a few years, worked a few odd jobs, got married, got separated, spent some time in Atlanta, and by the end of 2011, a few months after the murders in Waltham, he had moved to Florida. But one detail caught my attention. At the time of his death, Ibragim had been living with a woman named Tatiana Gruzdeva.
他2008年从车臣移民到波士顿，在那里住了几年，打了几份零工，结了婚，又分居了，在亚特兰大待了一段时间，到2011年底，也就是沃尔瑟姆谋杀案发生几个月后，他搬到了佛罗里达。但有一个细节引起了我的注意。在他去世时，易卜拉欣正与一名叫塔蒂亚娜·格鲁兹德娃（Tatiana Gruzdeva）的女子同居。
The Boston Globe wrote that Tatiana had been detained for having an expired visa, and was on her way to being deported to Moscow. But later, they reported that Tatiana had been mysteriously released, and was still living in Florida. I found her the way anyone finds anybody, on Facebook.
《波士顿环球报》报道称，塔蒂亚娜因签证过期被拘留，即将被遣返回莫斯科。但后来他们报道说，塔蒂亚娜被神秘地释放了，而且仍住在佛罗里达。我通过每个人找人的方式找到了她——Facebook。
A slight 19-year-old with bleach blond hair and huge green eyes, she posted a lot of selfies. Impulsively, I sent her a friend request. It didn't surprise me that she didn't respond.
她是个19岁的瘦弱女孩，染着一头漂白过的金发，有着巨大的绿眼睛，她发了很多自拍。我冲动之下给她发了好友请求。她没有回复，我并不感到惊讶。
Months went by. Then, one night in September, while I was working on my computer in my living room, a little alert appeared on my screen. Tatiana accepted my Facebook request.
几个月过去了。然后，九月的一个晚上，当我在客厅用电脑工作时，屏幕上弹出了一个提醒。塔蒂亚娜接受了我的Facebook好友请求。
We started messaging. Soon we switched to the phone. The first time I talked to Tatiana, I didn't know it was going to be doing a radio story. I don't have an audio recording, but I took notes, and I tried to get down as much of her rapid fire, Russian accented voice as possible. She told me she'd only known Ibragim for six months.
我们开始互发信息。很快就转为电话联系。第一次和塔蒂亚娜谈话时，我不知道这会变成一个广播报道。我没有录音，但我做了笔记，并尽量记录下她那种语速极快、带着俄语口音的声音。她告诉我她认识易卜拉欣才六个月。
They began as roommates. First it was just friends, she told me, and after, "we started having relationship, and we were sleeping together like boyfriend and girlfriend."
他们起初是室友。她说，最初只是朋友，后来，“我们开始谈恋爱，就像男朋友和女朋友一样住在一起。”
Tatiana told me the night Ibragim was shot was not the first time he talked to the FBI. I think most people had the impression that the FBI showed up, started asking Ibragim about a murder, he freaked out, and they shot him. In fact, though, both Tatiana and Ibragim had been cooperating with them for more than a month.
塔蒂亚娜告诉我，易卜拉欣被枪杀的那天晚上并不是他第一次和FBI谈话。我想大多数人的印象是FBI突然找上门，开始询问易卜拉欣关于谋杀案的事，他吓坏了，于是他们就开枪打死了他。但事实上，塔蒂亚娜和易卜拉欣与他们配合已经超过一个月了。
The relationship with the FBI had become almost cordial, businesslike. Agents contacted the couple regularly on the phone, visited their home, and called them into the FBI offices for more questioning. I wanted to know what they were asking about. Did it seem like the FBI had connected Ibragim to the Waltham murders? Were they asking about them?
这种与FBI的关系已经变得近乎客气、公事公办。探员经常给这对情侣打电话、去他们家拜访，并把他们叫到FBI办公室接受更多询问。我想知道他们都在问些什么。FBI似乎把易卜拉欣和沃尔瑟姆谋杀案联系起来了吗？他们在询问这起案子吗？
Tatiana said no. Waltham didn't come up, as far as she knew. She said their questions for Ibragim were mostly about terrorism, the Boston bombing, and his relationship with Tamerlan Tsarnaev. Ibragim admitted he was friends with Tamerlan back when he lived in Boston. She said the agents asked about a phone call Tamerlan made to Ibragim about a month before the marathon bombing.
塔蒂亚娜说没有。据她所知，沃尔瑟姆案从未提起过。她说他们对易卜拉欣的询问大多是关于恐怖主义、波士顿爆炸案以及他与塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫的关系。易卜拉欣承认他在波士顿居住时曾与塔梅尔兰是朋友。她说探员们询问了塔梅尔兰在马拉松爆炸案发生前大约一个月给易卜拉欣打过的一个电话。
Ibragim told them the call was nothing important, that Tamerlan was just checking up on Ibragim after he had surgery on his knee. But later, Ibragim deleted the call from his phone history. When agents asked him why, Ibragim told them he was scared.
易卜拉欣告诉他们那通电话没什么重要的，只是塔梅尔兰在他做完膝盖手术后关心一下他的情况。但后来，易卜拉欣从他的通话记录中删除了那个电话。当探员问他原因时，易卜拉欣告诉他们他很害怕。
Then, three weeks into the interviews, Tatiana was in the lobby of the FBI office, waiting for Ibragim to be done with another round of questioning, and an agent asked her to come with him. It's fine, she says they told her. Ibragim knows about it.
接着，在审讯进行了三周后，塔蒂亚娜在FBI办公室的大厅里等易卜拉欣结束另一轮审讯，一名探员要求她跟他走一趟。她说他们告诉她没关系的，易卜拉欣知道这件事。
She went to a room with them. They asked her a bunch of familiar questions about the marathon bombing. And then they brought up something new.
她和他们进了房间。他们问了她一连串关于马拉松爆炸案的老问题。然后他们提出了一个新的问题。
We think he did something else before, in Boston, 2011, with a knife, Tatiana says they told her. It was the first time Tatiana had ever heard about the Waltham triple murder. She told the agents she didn't believe that Ibragim had anything to do with it. She said the agents then asked her if she'd be willing to let them know if Ibragim started doing anything suspicious, basically to inform on him.
塔蒂亚娜说他们告诉她：“我们认为他在2011年之前在波士顿用刀做过别的事。”那是塔蒂亚娜第一次听说沃尔瑟姆三尸命案。她告诉探员她不相信易卜拉欣与此有任何关系。她说探员随后问她如果易卜拉欣开始做任何可疑的事情，她是否愿意告诉他们，基本上就是让她当告密者。
She says she said no, because he wasn't doing anything, and she didn't know anything. So the agents called immigration, and they locked her up. She was in the States on an expired student visa.
她说她拒绝了，因为他没做任何事，而且她什么都不知道。于是探员给移民局打了电话，把她关了起来。她是以过期的学生签证留在美国的。
Tatiana was held in an immigration detention facility for a week. The day after Ibragim was shot, she was transferred to the Glades County Detention Center and placed in a medical unit. She asked officers why she was being moved, and they told her they'd tell her in the morning.
塔蒂亚娜在移民拘留所被关了一周。在易卜拉欣被枪杀的第二天，她被转移到格莱兹县拘留中心，并被安置在医疗单元。她问官员为什么要转移她，他们告诉她早上会告诉她原因。
The next day, she learned the truth. Her boyfriend was dead. She didn't return home for another 11 weeks, to the apartment she'd once shared with Ibragim.
第二天，她得知了真相。她的男朋友死了。她在那之后的11周才回到那个她曾与易卜拉欣共享的公寓。
I'm just gonna leave the recorder running.
我准备让录音机一直开着。
All right.
好。
Three days after I talked to Tatiana on the phone, I flew down to Orlando to meet with her in person. And this time, I brought a tape recorder. But sitting in the tiny living room of her apartment, the room where Ibragim had been killed, she was much more reluctant to talk about Ibragim or the FBI or, really, much of anything.
我和塔蒂亚娜通完电话三天后，我飞往奥兰多亲自见她。这次，我带了录音机。但坐在她那狭小的公寓客厅里，也就是易卜拉欣被杀的那个房间，她对谈论易卜拉欣、FBI，或者说谈论任何事情都变得更加抗拒。
What first made you fall in love with Ibragim?
是什么让你第一次爱上易卜拉欣的？
I really don't want to do this.
我真的不想这么做。
One reason Tatiana was scared, why she responded to my Facebook request at all weeks after I sent it, was because earlier that same day, she and her friend had been driving when they got pulled over by six or seven unmarked police cars and her friend was taken away. She didn't know who had taken him or why, but she was afraid she might be next.
塔蒂亚娜感到害怕的一个原因，也是为什么她在发完请求几周后才回复我的Facebook请求，是因为就在同一天早些时候，她和朋友开车时被六七辆便衣警车拦下，她的朋友被带走了。她不知道是谁带走了他或原因是什么，但她很担心自己可能是下一个。
I know, but I'm really scared, you know, about just--
我知道，但我真的很害怕，你知道，关于——
I understand that you're just scared, like, in general.
我理解你只是很害怕，大概是这样。
Because after this jail, and right after, I'm really scared.
因为在坐牢之后，而且紧接着发生这些，我真的很害怕。
It was also weird being in that apartment with a 19-year-old girl whose bed was covered with stuffed animals. She showed me a video she'd taken with her phone of her and Ibragim in a Hallmark type store on Valentine's Day. She's giggling and trying to get him to put on a silly hat. She seemed to be like any other teenage girl with a standoffish boyfriend.
待在那间公寓里也感觉很奇怪，那儿住着一个床上铺满毛绒玩具的19岁女孩。她给我看了一段她用手机拍的视频，那是情人节时她和易卜拉欣在一家礼品店里的场景。她咯咯笑着，试图让他戴上一顶滑稽的帽子。她看起来就像任何其他有一个高冷男朋友的少女一样。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（讲外语）
She knew about my connection to the Waltham murders. She knew that her boyfriend is thought to be the person who killed my friend. But she didn't think it was even slightly possible he did it.
她知道我和沃尔瑟姆谋杀案的联系。她知道她的男朋友被认为是那个杀害我朋友的人。但她认为他做了这件事的可能性甚至微乎其微。
I tried not to push her on that point, but it was practically all I could think about. Did her dead boyfriend slit my friend's throat? Instead, I told her I thought it was wrong of the FBI to kill Ibragim, even if he was a murderer. After a few hours of talking, I decided to leave Tatiana alone.
我尽量不去在那一点上逼迫她，但那几乎是我脑子里唯一能想到的事。她死去的男朋友割断了我朋友的喉咙吗？相反，我告诉她，我认为即使易卜拉欣是个杀人犯，FBI杀死他也是不对的。谈了几个小时后，我决定让塔蒂亚娜独自待着。
Well, keep in touch with me. If something happens, you know, and you-- keep in touch with me. Let me know what's going on.
好吧，保持联系。如果发生什么事，你知道，还有你——跟我保持联系。让我知道情况进展。
All right. I hope nothing.
好的。希望什么都不会发生。
Hopefully nothing, but-- nothing bad's going to ever happen to you, but--
希望如此，但是——没什么坏事会发生在你身上，但是——
I hope. I hope not, because it's already a lot.
我希望。我希望不要，因为这已经够多了。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）
OK, OK, Tatiana, who-- who-- who is the immigration officer who told you that you're here because of an interview you gave to me?
好的，好的，塔蒂亚娜，那个告诉你是由于接受了我采访才被关在这里的移民局官员是谁？
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）
Give me the--
告诉我——
A week after I left Orlando, Tatiana called me from an immigration detention facility. She told me because she did that interview with me, and I wrote a story about it for Boston magazine's website, she was now being deported.
我离开奥兰多一周后，塔蒂亚娜从移民拘留所打来电话。她告诉我，因为她接受了我的采访，而我为《波士顿》杂志网站写了一篇相关报道，她现在要被遣返了。
I can't believe that that's happened, though. And if that's the only reason, it's really concerning.
我简直不敢相信这发生了。如果这是唯一的原因，那真的很令人不安。
Right? It's stupid, right? It's crazy! I can't believe it's true, but-- because of this interview.
对吧？很蠢，对吧？太疯狂了！我不敢相信这是真的，但是——是因为这次采访。
After Tatiana had been released from detention the first time, she was given a special permission to stay in the US-- something called deferred action. Now she was telling me that permission had been revoked.
塔蒂亚娜第一次从拘留所被释放后，她获得了留在美国的特别许可——一种叫做“延期行动”（deferred action）的政策。现在她告诉我那个许可被撤销了。
Because now they're still overstating that.
因为现在他们还在强调那个。
Have you been speaking to the FBI since you've been detained?
你被拘留后一直在和FBI谈话吗？
No, no. Oh my god. Thank god, no. I don't want to talk to them. Maybe I will have more problems now.
不，不。天哪。谢天谢地，没有。我不想和他们说话。也许我以后会有更多麻烦。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
I wanted to [INAUDIBLE].
我想（听不清）。
OK.
好的。
I want to be-- I just want to be deported. I just want to see my mom, my family. I just want to go to Russia. But I want to be safe in Russia. I don't want to stay here anymore in the jail.
我想被——我只想被遣返。我只想见到我的妈妈，我的家人。我只想去俄罗斯。但我希望在俄罗斯是安全的。我不想再待在这里的监狱里了。
I frantically called immigration officers to find out what was going on. They wouldn't tell me anything. Later, when I asked again, they referred me to the FBI. But the FBI wouldn't talk about it.
我疯狂地打电话给移民局官员想弄清楚发生了什么。他们什么也不愿告诉我。后来，当我再次询问时，他们让我去找FBI。但FBI拒绝讨论此事。
After spending 10 days in jail, two immigration agents accompanied Tatiana on her flight back to Moscow. Even when she got home to her mom's house in Moldova, she told me she was too scared to do another interview.
在监狱里待了10天后，两名移民局探员陪同塔蒂亚娜登上了飞往莫斯科的航班。即使在她回到摩尔多瓦母亲家中后，她仍告诉我，由于太害怕，她不敢再接受采访。
I called around to a few immigration lawyers, because I wanted to know if it's even legal to deport someone for speaking to the press. It turns out, because of Tatiana's status, it was. Under her deferred action, Tatiana was legally allowed to stay in the US for another year. Now that she'd talked to me, her stay was mysteriously cut 10 months short.
我打电话咨询了几位移民律师，因为我想知道为了接受媒体采访而遣返某人是否合法。结果发现，由于塔蒂亚娜的身份，这是合法的。根据她的“延期行动”资格，塔蒂亚娜在法律上有权在美国再待一年。现在因为她和我谈话，她的停留时间神秘地缩短了10个月。
But why? What didn't the FBI want her to say to me? Or maybe they were trying to send a message to other people who might talk. I did notice the FBI seemed to be paying a lot of attention to anyone who was close to Ibragim.
但是为什么呢？FBI不想让她对我说什么？或者他们是在试图向其他可能开口的人发出信号。我确实注意到FBI似乎对任何与易卜拉欣亲近的人都给予了高度关注。
In these recent weeks, how much contact have you had with the FBI?
最近几周，你和FBI有多少接触？
Me?
我吗？
This is Ibragim's best friend in Florida, Khusen Taramov. The morning after Ibragim died, he talked to TV reporters with another friend of Ibragim's who didn't want to be identified.
这是易卜拉欣在佛罗里达最好的朋友库森·塔拉莫夫（Khusen Taramov）。易卜拉欣去世后的第二天早上，他和易卜拉欣的另一位不想透露姓名的朋友接受了电视记者采访。
They've been following us. They're watching us. Every time we go somewhere, there's two, three cops undercover. We see them.
他们一直跟着我们。他们监视着我们。每次我们去什么地方，都有两三个便衣警察。我们看到了他们。
You know what I mean? Like, they still watch us all the time. They know everything about us-- where we from, what are we doing.
你明白我的意思吗？他们还在一直监视着我们。他们知道关于我们的一切——我们来自哪里，我们在做什么。
They know everything.
他们知道一切。
Everything. Everything. Everything. So--
一切。一切。一切。所以——
Khusen had actually been with Ibragim the night he was killed. He went with Ibragim to the final interview at his apartment, but agents told them to wait outside. They wanted to question Ibragim alone.
易卜拉欣被杀的那晚，库森实际上和易卜拉欣在一起。他和易卜拉欣一起去了他公寓的那场最终审讯，但探员让他们在外面等。他们想单独审问易卜拉欣。
Khusen waited outside for four hours before being told to leave. About an hour later, Ibragim was shot. I wanted to talk to Khusen about this, but when I reached out to him, I learned something strange. Khusen had gone to Russia on July 4th to see his family, and when he tried to come back to the US afterwards, authorities wouldn't let Khusen or his two brothers on the plane, with no explanation.
库森在外面等了四个小时才被告知离开。大约一个小时后，易卜拉欣被枪杀。我想和库森谈谈这件事，但当我联系他时，我发现了一件奇怪的事。库森7月4日去俄罗斯看望家人，当他之后尝试回到美国时，当局拒绝让他和他的两个兄弟登机，没有任何解释。
Khusen has a green card. He went to high school in the States. But for some reason, he's not being let back into the country now. When I finally did get a hold of Khusen, he said he didn't want to do an interview. He just wanted to put everything behind him.
库森有绿卡。他在美国读过高中。但出于某种原因，他现在无法回到这个国家。当我最终联系上库森时，他说他不想接受采访。他只想把一切抛在脑后。
Here's one more thing. The FBI stopped the medical examiner from releasing Ibragim's autopsy report. The only reason we know how many times he was shot was because pictures were taken of Ibragim's embalmed body. Khusen is the one who took those pictures.
还有一件事。FBI阻止法医公布易卜拉欣的尸检报告。我们知道他被开了几枪的唯一原因是因为有人拍了他遗体的照片。库森就是拍下那些照片的人。
So here's what I was working with. The FBI killed Ibragim. They released no official information about exactly what happened and wouldn't say when they would release that information. And then these people close to Ibragim were whisked away. His girlfriend, his best friend-- both of them were kept out of the country. I didn't know if it was a cover up, but it just didn't look right.
所以，这就是我所面对的情况。FBI杀了易卜拉欣。他们没有发布关于到底发生了什么的官方信息，也不愿说何时会发布信息。然后这些与易卜拉欣亲近的人就被迅速赶走了。他的女朋友、他最好的朋友——他们都被拦在了美国境外。我不知道这是否是一种掩盖，但这看起来实在是不对劲。
Susan Zalkind. Coming up, a third person close to Ibragim is politely ushered out of the country by federal authorities. And at the end of the hour, our theory about the truth behind all this. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
苏珊·扎尔金德。接下来，第三个与易卜拉欣亲近的人被联邦当局礼貌地赶出了美国。在节目结束时，我们将给出我们关于这一切真相的理论。一分钟后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. All this hour, we're hearing Susan Zalkind's investigation into a few deaths-- a triple murder in Waltham, Massachusetts in 2011, where a friend of hers was one of the victims, and a killing last May where the FBI shot a man, Ibragim Todashev, in his own apartment in Florida seven times while questioning him about the triple murder.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。这一整小时，我们都在听苏珊·扎尔金德对几起死亡事件的调查——一起是2011年马萨诸塞州沃尔瑟姆的三尸命案，她的一位朋友是受害者之一；另一起是去年五月的杀人案，易卜拉欣·托达舍夫在佛罗里达的公寓里，在接受关于那起三尸命案的审讯时被FBI开了七枪打死。
So far, as you have heard, Susan has found that two of the people closest to Todashev, his girlfriend and his best friend, have both been more or less booted out of the United States. And there's a third person who was close to Ibragim whose story is even stranger, Ashur Miraliev. That's where we'll pick up. Here's Susan.
到目前为止，正如你们所听到的，苏珊发现，与托达舍夫最亲近的两个人，他的女朋友和他最好的朋友，基本上都被踢出了美国。还有一个与易卜拉欣亲近的人，他的故事更离奇，阿舒尔·米拉利耶夫（Ashur Miraliev）。我们就从这里继续。下面请听苏珊的讲述。
It took five months to convince Ashur to talk to me. When I first heard about him, he was in a maximum security prison in Florida. Nine weeks later, he was deported to Tajikistan. During all this time, I reached out again and again, and he just kept turning me down. His lawyer said he didn't want to talk because he'd been traumatized, having his friend killed by the FBI and then being arrested himself. But finally, a month ago--
我花了五个月才说服阿舒尔和我谈谈。当我第一次听到关于他的消息时，他被关在佛罗里达的一所最高安全级别的监狱里。九周后，他被遣返回塔吉克斯坦。在这期间，我一次又一次地联系他，但他一直拒绝我。他的律师说他不想谈，因为他受到了创伤，经历了朋友被FBI杀害，自己也被捕。但最终，一个月前——
Are you there?
你在吗？
Can you hear me?
能听到我说话吗？
Yeah. Can you hear me?
是的。能听到吗？
Yes.
可以。
We talked over an internet phone line. Ashur moved to Florida in 2011 on a student visa. He started hanging out with a crew of Russian speakers, and that's how he met Ibragim. Ashur is only 20 years old, so he was nearly eight years younger than Ibragim.
我们通过网络电话进行了交流。阿舒尔2011年持学生签证搬到佛罗里达。他开始和一群讲俄语的人混在一起，这就是他结识易卜拉欣的方式。阿舒尔只有20岁，所以他比易卜拉欣小了近八岁。
He said they had a good friendship, but because of the age difference, it wasn't super close. Ibragim didn't confide in him. He said Ibragim was more like a brother than a friend.
他说他们之间有很好的友谊，但由于年龄差距，并不是特别亲密。易卜拉欣并没有向他吐露心声。他说易卜拉欣更像是个哥哥，而不是朋友。
Ashur was questioned once by the FBI about Ibragim two days before Ibragim died. But after an FBI agent shot Ibragim during an interview, Ashur and his friends decided they didn't want to sit down for any more interviews themselves. They stopped cooperating.
易卜拉欣死前两天，阿舒尔曾被FBI审问过一次关于易卜拉欣的事情。但在一名FBI探员在审讯过程中枪杀易卜拉欣后，阿舒尔和他的朋友们决定他们不想再参加任何审讯了。他们停止了配合。
Four months passed. It seemed like the FBI had moved on, until a Wednesday afternoon in September when Ashur was driving near Universal Studios and an undercover car pulled him over.
四个月过去了。看起来FBI已经不再理会他们，直到九月的一个周三下午，阿舒尔开车经过环球影城附近时，一辆便衣警车拦下了他。
And then there was a bunch of cars, like five, six cars were right after them.
然后有很多车，大概五六辆车就在他们后面。
Why did they say they were pulling you over?
他们说为什么要拦下你？
Because my driver's license was expired.
因为我的驾照过期了。
That's the only reason they told you you were being pulled over by seven undercover--
这就是他们告诉你七辆便衣警车拦下你的唯一理由？
Yes.
是的。
--cops? They said your driver's license was expired?
警察？他们说是你的驾照过期了？
Yes.
是的。
Ashur says people who identified themselves as FBI agents asked him to come to their office.
阿舒尔说自称是FBI探员的人要求他去他们的办公室。
They told me that, like, let's go to the office, you know, there's air conditioning, blah, blah, blah. We can chill and talk, you know?
他们告诉我，比如，去办公室吧，你知道，那里有空调，等等等等。我们可以坐下来聊聊，你知道？
Did they tell you what they wanted to talk about? So you have an expired license. Did they say they wanted to talk about that?
他们告诉你他们想聊什么了吗？所以你只是驾照过期。他们说想谈那个吗？
Yeah. I told them, what do you want to talk about? Like, what do you want? And they just kept saying, let's go to the office, you know? We're gonna talk over there. You can stop the conversation anytime you want, you know? You can come back at any time you want, blah, blah, blah, you know?
是的。我告诉他们，你们想谈什么？你们想要什么？他们只是一直说，去办公室吧，你知道？我们会在那边谈。你随时可以停止对话，你知道？你随时想走就可以走，等等等等，你知道？
I was so shocked. I was so shocked, and I was so interested. From one side, I wanted to go with them, because I was so interested. I wanted to know what they want for me, like, you know? So I decided to go with them, because I was so scared. I was so shocked. And it was so interesting, you know?
我当时太震惊了。我太震惊了，而且我也很好奇。一方面，我想和他们走，因为我太好奇了。我想知道他们从我这里想要什么，就像，你知道？所以我决定和他们走，因为我太害怕了。我太震惊了。而且这一切太有意思了，你知道？
Ashur was driven to a police station where they entered this in their system as merely a traffic stop, no other information. But according to documents from the County Sheriff's department, Ashur was soon headed over to the FBI, where he says agents aggressively questioned him about his relationship with Ibragim. They were convinced that he'd been one of Ibragim's closest friends, that he had to know something.
阿舒尔被带到一个警察局，他们将其系统里登记为一次普通的交通拦截，没有其他信息。但根据县治安官部门的文件，阿舒尔很快被转送到了FBI，他说探员们咄咄逼人地审问了他与易卜拉欣的关系。他们确信他曾是易卜拉欣最亲近的朋友之一，他肯定知道些什么。
What kind of information about Ibragim were they interested in?
他们对关于易卜拉欣的什么信息感兴趣？
Like, what kind of relationship he had with Tsarnaevs, when he was in the Boston. Do you know his Boston friends? Do you know who was with him at the time of triple murder, you know?
比如，他和萨纳耶夫兄弟是什么关系，他在波士顿的时候。你认识他波士顿的朋友吗？你知道三尸命案发生时谁和他在一起吗，你知道？
What do I know about triple murder? What did Ibragim told me about triple murder, you know? Like, these kids of questions.
我关于三尸命案知道什么？易卜拉欣关于三尸命案告诉过我什么，你知道？就是这些问题。
It surprised me that they were asking Ashur about the Waltham murders four months after Ibragim had been killed, four months after Ibragim had supposedly confessed. Ashur told me he knew nothing about the triple murder. He'd never met the Tsarnaevs. He's never even been to Boston.
易卜拉欣被杀四个月后，FBI还在问阿舒尔关于沃尔瑟姆谋杀案的事，这让我很惊讶，毕竟四个多月前易卜拉欣就已经“供认”了。阿舒尔告诉我他对比三尸命案一无所知。他从未见过萨纳耶夫兄弟。他甚至从未去过波士顿。
Did they imply that you had anything to do with this triple murder in Waltham?
他们暗示过你与沃尔瑟姆这起三尸命案有任何关系吗？
Me?
我吗？
Yeah. Was that what the--
是的。那是——
No, no.
不，不。
Was the FBI asking you about that?
FBI是在问你那个吗？
No. But they were pointing at Ibragim, like, for sure, you know?
没有。但他们确实把矛头指向了易卜拉欣，就是肯定是他，你知道？
Like for sure he did it?
就像肯定是他做的？
Yeah, exactly. They wasn't interested about me. They-- can you hear me?
对，确实。他们对我没兴趣。他们——能听到我吗？
Yeah, I hear you.
是的，我听到了。
They knew that I didn't do nothing. They wasn't interested about me. They just wanted to get some information from me, you know?
他们知道我什么都没做。他们对我没兴趣。他们只是想从我这里得到一些信息，你知道？
I couldn't figure out if the FBI thought Ashur actually knew something or if they were just fishing. It made me think that even if Ibragim confessed, they didn't have much evidence besides it. They needed anything they could find to close the case.
我搞不清楚FBI是认为阿舒尔真的知道些什么，还是仅仅在捕风捉影。这让我觉得，即使易卜拉欣招供了，除了他的话，他们也没什么证据。他们需要能找到的一切线索来结案。
How long did this interview go for, this first interview?
这次审讯持续了多久，第一次审讯？
Um, it was like a few hours. A few hours, yeah. And when I told them I wanted to stop the conversation, they told me you're gonna go to the jail, you know? That's the first time they told me about the jail. I really thought they were kidding, you know? Because I knew that I wouldn't go to the jail for my driver's license, because it was only nine days expired.
嗯，持续了几个小时。几个小时吧。当我告诉他们我想停止对话时，他们告诉我你会进监狱的，你知道？那是他们第一次提到监狱。我真的以为他们在开玩笑，你知道？因为我知道我就因为驾照过期不会坐牢，因为那才过期九天。
I could get only a ticket, you know? I thought they were kidding, but they weren't. They just put handcuffs on me. They took me to the jail. I went to the jail, you know?
我本可以只收到一张罚单，你知道？我以为他们在开玩笑，但他们不是。他们直接给我戴上手铐。他们把我带到监狱。我进了监狱，你知道？
Ashur had no idea what he was being arrested for, and when they told him, he couldn't believe it. He thought there was some mistake. I just want to stop here to take a detour in Ashur's story in order to explain his arrest charge. It sheds light on how the FBI was operating down in Florida in this case, and the lengths they were willing to go to get to Ashur.
阿舒尔根本不知道自己是因为什么被捕的，当他们告诉他时，他简直不敢相信。他以为是个误会。我想在这里停一下，绕个弯说明一下阿舒尔的指控。这揭示了FBI在此案中在佛罗里达的操作方式，以及他们为了抓到阿舒尔愿意采取的手段。
Ashur was arrested for threatening the victim of a crime. The formal charge was tampering with a victim by threat, and the story behind it starts here, at the Ali Baba Hookah Lounge just outside Orlando. Ali Baba sits in the front of a small shopping plaza on Polynesian Isle Boulevard. Disney World is down the road, but the plaza is like this international oasis in the middle of American tourist country. There's a small grocery store owned by Egyptians, a hair salon owned by an Iraqi Turkish guy, and the hookah bar, which is owned by a Moroccan.
阿舒尔因威胁犯罪受害者而被捕。正式罪名是“通过威胁干扰受害者”（tampering with a victim by threat），而这背后的故事始于这里，奥兰多郊外的阿里·巴巴水烟吧。阿里·巴巴坐落在波利尼西亚岛大道旁一个小购物广场的前面。迪士尼世界就在那条路尽头，但这个广场就像美国旅游区中间的一个国际绿洲。有一家埃及人拥有的小杂货店，一家伊拉克裔土耳其人拥有的美发沙龙，以及那家由摩洛哥人拥有的水烟吧。
The incident that put Ashur in jail happened here, and the person who pressed charges against Ashur was the manager of the hookah bar, this guy.
让阿舒尔进监狱的事件就发生在这里，而指控阿舒尔的人是水烟吧的经理，就是这家伙。
My name is Youness eit Dammou. I used to work at the Ali Baba Hookah Bar.
我叫尤尼斯·艾特·达穆（Youness eit Dammou）。我以前在阿里·巴巴水烟吧工作。
Youness actually works at a different hookah bar now, across the street. When my producer, Brian Reed, and I found Youness, it was midnight. He graciously sat down and told us the story of how he came to press charges against Ashur. It actually begins with Ibragim. One day, Youness says, Ibragim was at the hookah bar, and he was hitting on a woman who worked there, making her feel uncomfortable, so Youness went over to intervene.
尤尼斯现在在街对面另一家水烟吧工作。当我和制片人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）找到尤尼斯时，已经是午夜了。他很慷慨地坐下来，告诉了我们他是如何决定指控阿舒尔的故事。这其实始于易卜拉欣。尤尼斯说，有一天易卜拉欣在水烟吧，搭讪了一名在那里工作的女性，让她感到不舒服，于是尤尼斯过去干预。
Ibragim, he got a little bit frustrated and, you know, he thinks he can manage the place. I told him, honestly, I'm the manager over here. You're welcome. You can have a good time, you know, enjoy yourself. But if you want to rule this place as you want, you're welcome to leave. So obviously he didn't like what I said.
易卜拉欣变得有点沮丧，你知道，他以为他能管这个地方。我告诉他，说实话，我是这里的经理。欢迎光临。你可以玩得开心，你知道，享受你自己。但如果你想随心所欲地统治这里，那么欢迎你离开。显然他不喜欢我说的话。
After this, Youness says he walked over to the grocery store in the plaza. Ibragim followed him, telling Youness he wanted to go out back with him behind the plaza. Youness turned away, and then, all of a sudden--
在那之后，尤尼斯说他走到广场里的杂货店。易卜拉欣跟着他，告诉尤尼斯他想去广场后面跟他聊聊。尤尼斯转身离开，然后，突然间——
Boom! I lost consciousness.
砰！我失去了知觉。
Ibragim knocked Youness on the side of the head with his fist. A few seconds later, when Youness came to--
易卜拉欣用拳头猛击了尤尼斯的头部侧面。几秒钟后，当尤尼斯醒来——
He grabbed me from my legs, like this.
他抓住了我的腿，就像这样。
Youness says Ibragim lifted him high off the ground until Youness's knees were level with Ibragim's chest. Then Ibragim slammed him onto the sidewalk, like in a wrestling move. Remember, he was training to be a professional fighter. Ibragim climbed on top of him. At this point, a crowd had gathered, and Youness yelled for someone to call 911.
尤尼斯说易卜拉欣把他从地上高高举起，直到尤尼斯的膝盖与易卜拉欣的胸部齐平。然后易卜拉欣把他猛摔在人行道上，就像一个摔跤动作。记住，他曾训练成为一名职业格斗选手。易卜拉欣骑在他身上。此时，人群聚集了起来，尤尼斯大喊让人拨打911。
He heard me say, call 911. He ran to his car and ran.
他听到我说拨打911。他跑向车子逃走了。
When police came, Youness told him everything he knew about Ibragim, which wasn't much. He didn't even remember his last name. After police left, Youness was trying to get more information about the guy who beat him up, so he went to a pizza shop next door where he'd seen Ibragim hanging out a lot.
当警察来时，尤尼斯告诉了他们关于易卜拉欣所知的一切，其实并不多。他甚至记不得他的姓。警察走后，尤尼斯试图寻找更多关于那个打他的人的信息，于是他去了隔壁一家易卜拉欣经常在那闲逛的披萨店。
That's when he ran into Ashur. Ashur was a delivery guy there, and Youness says Ashur didn't like the fact that he was asking about Ibragim.
就在那时他遇到了阿舒尔。阿舒尔是那里的外卖员，尤尼斯说阿舒尔不喜欢他打听易卜拉欣的事。
When I asked, Ashur got pissed, and he told me, you're not a man. Why you call the cops? Why you didn't fight him like a man? He starts cursing, and he was coming toward me.
当我打听时，阿舒尔很生气，他告诉我，你不是个男人。你为什么要报警？你为什么不像个男人一样和他打架？他开始咒骂，并朝我走来。
Did he threaten you?
他威胁你了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
What did he say?
他说了什么？
I don't remember exactly, but it's like he wanted to provoke me to get into a fight.
我不记得确切的字句，但就像他想挑衅我，让我去打架。
And did you consider calling the police?
那你考虑过报警吗？
No, I didn't, because I'd just called him like an hour and a half ago, something like that. There is better things for the police to do than a fight between me and someone, you know what I mean?
没有，我没有，因为我一个半小时前刚打过电话，差不多是这样。警察有比处理我和某人打架更好的事情要做，你明白我的意思吗？
This incident, this little shouting match, this is what Ashur ended up being arrested for. Because Ashur yelled at Youness for calling the police on Ibragim. This is the tampering with a victim charge.
这次事件，这场小争吵，就是阿舒尔最终被捕的原因。因为阿舒尔大声斥责尤尼斯报警抓易卜拉欣。这就是那项“干扰受害者”的指控。
What makes this especially strange is that Ashur wasn't arrested until more than a year later, even though he worked right next door to Youness. That's because in all that time, Youness never thought this was a big enough deal to even call the police about. Youness's only beef was with Ibragim for beating him up.
特别奇怪的是，阿舒尔直到一年多后才被捕，尽管他在尤尼斯隔壁工作。那是因为在这段时间里，尤尼斯从未觉得这事大到需要报警。尤尼斯唯一的怨气是针对易卜拉欣打了他。
He did want to press charges against him, but 10 months went by, and there was never an arrest. Then the Boston Marathon is bombed, and Youness says one day, out of the blue, an FBI agent met with him, along with a detective from Osceola County, who asked if he still wanted to press charges against Ibragim.
他确实想指控易卜拉欣，但10个月过去了，一直没有逮捕行动。然后波士顿马拉松被炸了，尤尼斯说有一天，毫无预兆地，一名FBI探员带着一名奥西奥拉县（Osceola County）的侦探找上门，问他是否还想指控易卜拉欣。
Did they mention the Boston Marathon bombing?
他们提到波士顿马拉松爆炸案了吗？
No. No. We didn't discuss that. The things that we discussed is the fights, and they want me to press charges. And I press charges.
没有。没有。我们没有讨论那个。我们讨论的是那次打架，他们想要我指控他。我就指控了。
Now, if this were a normal case, police would take those charges and go arrest Ibragim. But for some reason, he wasn't arrested. Just four days later, Ibragim was dead.
现在，如果是普通的案子，警察会拿着这些指控去抓易卜拉欣。但出于某种原因，他没被抓。仅仅四天后，易卜拉欣就死了。
Three months went by, and Youness got another visit, again from the Osceola County detective. This time, he asked if Youness wanted to press charges against Ashur. And Youness said OK.
三个月过去了，尤尼斯又接到了拜访，还是那位奥西奥拉县的侦探。这次，他问尤尼斯是否想指控阿舒尔。尤尼斯说可以。
About three weeks later, Ashur was pulled over by the undercover cars and taken for the FBI interview. Which brings us back to the moment FBI agents told him he was under arrest.
大约三周后，阿舒尔被便衣警车拦下，并被带去参加FBI的审讯。这就让我们回到了FBI探员告诉他被捕的那一刻。
I asked them, why am I here? Why am I in a jail? What are the charges, you know?
我问他们，我为什么在这里？我为什么在监狱里？指控是什么，你知道？
Again, Ashur Miraliev.
再次回到阿舒尔·米拉利耶夫。
And they said, do you remember the incident with Youness over there in a hookah bar? I said, yes, so what? They said, that's why you're here.
他们说，你记得水烟吧发生的那次事件吗？我说，记得，那又怎样？他们说，这就是你在这里的原因。
Ashur thought there must be some mistake, so much so that as soon as he got booked into jail, he said he wanted to talk to the FBI again.
阿舒尔认为一定是个误会，以至于他一进监狱就说他想再次和FBI谈话。
He drove me back to the agents. I told them, hey, guys, it's impossible, you know? Are you guys kidding or something? I just couldn't believe. They told me that they have nothing to do with that.
他把我带回探员那里。我告诉他们，嘿，伙计们，这不可能，你知道？你们是在开玩笑吗？我简直不敢相信。他们告诉我，他们和那个毫无关系。
It's the state. State has some charges on me, you know? That's all what they told me, that they don't know nothing about my charges. They don't know nothing.
这是州里的事。州对我有一些指控，你知道？他们就告诉我这些，他们不知道关于我的指控的事。他们什么都不知道。
It's not true that the FBI knew nothing about this charge. A spokeswoman from the Osceola County Sheriff's Office confirmed that an FBI agent named Sykes was there for some of Youness's questioning. And Ashur's arrest affidavit said Agent Sykes is the one who gave them Ashur's name.
FBI什么都不知道是不真实的。奥西奥拉县治安官办公室的一位发言人证实，一名叫赛克斯（Sykes）的FBI探员确实在场参与了尤尼斯的部分审讯。而阿舒尔的逮捕证词上写着，是赛克斯探员给了他们阿舒尔的名字。
That wasn't all, though. On his booking papers, along with the tampering with a victim charge, Ashur was given this designation with no explanation-- "on terrorist watch list," "police protective custody," and "high risk, house alone."
那还不是全部。在他的登记文件上，除了“干扰受害者”的指控外，阿舒尔还被赋予了这个标签，没有任何解释——“恐怖分子观察名单”、“警方保护性羁押”、“高风险，独自居住”。
I should maybe be explicit here. Never once was it alleged, either in a formal charge or even in informal leaks, that Ashur had anything to do with the Boston bombings. The most you can say is how Ashur himself puts it. He knew a guy who knew a guy who supposedly committed the marathon bombings.
我在这里可能需要明确一下。无论是在正式指控中还是非正式泄密中，从未有人声称阿舒尔与波士顿爆炸案有任何关系。最多你只能说出阿舒尔本人的说法：他认识一个人，那个人认识据称犯下马拉松爆炸案的人。
For the crime of yelling at Youness, Ashur spent 33 days in a maximum security cell-- an 8' by 10' room where he spent all day alone. There were no windows. Just a slit in the door looking out to the lobby. The lights were always on, and he was always cold.
因为对尤尼斯大喊大叫的罪行，阿舒尔在最高安全级别的牢房里待了33天——一个8英尺乘10英尺的房间，他整天独自待在那里。没有窗户。门上只有一个狭缝，可以看到走廊。灯总是亮着，而且他一直很冷。
I talked to his attorney, a woman named Thania Diaz Clevenger, who, after trying for several days, and experiencing what she said was the most trouble she's ever had trying to locate a client, was finally able to meet with Ashur. This is how she described him in jail.
我和他的律师谈过，一个名叫塔尼亚·迪亚兹·克莱文格（Thania Diaz Clevenger）的女士。在尝试了好几天并经历了她所说的在寻找客户方面遇到过的最大麻烦后，她终于见到了阿舒尔。她这样描述在监狱里的他。
He was broken. He was petrified and broken and crying. And they chained him, arms, legs. He had the belly chain. Two guards walked with us down the hall to another room where they chained him to the ground, and he begged me not to go.
他崩溃了。他被吓坏了，崩溃了，在哭。他们锁着他，胳膊、腿。他戴着腹部锁链。两名警卫陪我们沿着走廊走到另一个房间，在那里他们把他锁在地板上，他乞求我不要走。
The charge that got Ashur thrown in prison, tampering with the victim of a crime, was dropped after a month. The state attorney's office wrote, quote, "This case is not suitable for prosecution." But for Ashur, it was too late.
导致阿舒尔被关进监狱的指控——干扰受害者——在一个月后被撤销。州检察官办公室写道：“此案不适合起诉。”但对阿舒尔来说，已经太晚了。
When he was arrested, his visa had already expired. He was in the process of applying for asylum, but he missed a court date while he was in jail. So when he was moved out of maximum security, they transferred him to an immigration jail. Nine weeks after the Orlando PD pulled him over for the traffic stop, he was deported back to Tajikistan, leaving behind his apartment, all of his belongings, his clothes, his money, and his car.
他被捕时，签证已经过期。他正在申请庇护，但因为在监狱里错过了法庭日期。所以当他从最高安全级别牢房转移出来时，他们把他转到了移民监狱。在奥兰多警方因交通拦截拦下他九周后，他被遣返回塔吉克斯坦，留下了他的公寓、所有的随身物品、衣服、钱和汽车。
Ashur's story seems so extreme. For a guy who just knew a guy who knew a guy, the government took pretty drastic measures against him. And when you add what they did to Ashur to the fact that Tatiana and Khusen are also being kept out of the country, it's hard not to ask, why is the FBI doing this? Are they cleaning up their mess? Trying to hide something? I asked a former FBI agent named Don Borelli what he thought.
阿舒尔的故事看起来太极端了。对于一个只是认识一个认识那个人的人，政府对他采取了相当严厉的措施。当你把他经历的事与塔蒂亚娜和库森也被拦在国外的事实加在一起时，很难不去问，FBI为什么要这么做？他们是在清理烂摊子吗？试图掩盖什么吗？我问了一位名叫唐·博雷利（Don Borelli）的前FBI探员他的看法。
If you think that this is some conspiracy to get these people out of the limelight where you're basically trying to suppress a story or a cover up or anything, I don't believe that that's the case at all.
如果你认为这是一场阴谋，为了把这些人排除在公众视野之外，你本质上是在试图抑制一个报道或掩盖什么，我不相信情况是那样。
What happened to Ashur, Tatiana, and Khusen doesn't make a lot of sense for a murder case, but it does for a terrorism case, which, of course, this was. Don worked at the FBI for 25 years and did a lot of terrorism cases. He doesn't have inside knowledge of the investigation into Ibragim, but I told him about the tactics used against Ibragim's friends-- deportations, no fly lists, arresting someone on local charges. He says these are all standard in a terrorism investigation for anyone who has any connections to the case.
发生在阿舒尔、塔蒂亚娜和库森身上的事对于谋杀案来说讲不通，但对于恐怖主义案件就讲得通了，当然，这起案子确实是。唐在FBI工作了25年，处理过很多恐怖主义案件。他没有关于易卜拉欣调查的内幕消息，但我告诉了他针对易卜拉欣朋友所采取的策略——遣返、禁飞名单、以当地指控逮捕某人。他说这些都是恐怖主义调查中针对任何与案件有联系的人的标准操作。
It may be third or four persons removed, but that's the nature of a terrorism investigation. You cast a very wide net. So yeah, if you can keep people out of the country that you think could potentially do harm or aid others in doing harm or whatever, you know, even provide financing, for example, then you are obligated to do that. That's your job to do that.
可能隔了三四个人，但这就是恐怖主义调查的本质。你撒了一张非常大的网。所以是的，如果你能让那些你认为可能潜在造成伤害或协助他人造成伤害的人——哪怕是提供资金——离开这个国家，那你就有义务这么做。那是你的工作。
Don says that even if it doesn't seem like you're going to do any harm, if you can be deported, standard procedure in terrorism cases is to deport you unless you can offer something to federal agents that makes it worth it to keep you around. In other words, there could be a logical explanation for keeping Ashur, Tatiana, and Khusen out of the country that doesn't involve a cover up.
唐说，即使看起来你好像不会造成任何伤害，如果可以遣返，恐怖主义案件中的标准程序就是遣返你，除非你能向联邦探员提供一些值得保留你的价值的东西。换句话说，保留阿舒尔、塔蒂亚娜和库森在国外可能有一个合乎逻辑的解释，并不涉及掩盖真相。
But that still doesn't explain the many weird things going on in this case. It doesn't explain why the FBI has taken so long-- nearly 10 months-- to release the report on Ibragim's shooting. It doesn't tell us what to make of Ibragim's supposed confession or what brought agents to his living room in the first place, whether they have any solid proof at all linking Ibragim or Tamerlan Tsarnaev to the murders.
但这仍然不能解释此案中发生的许多奇怪的事情。它不能解释为什么FBI花了这么长时间——近10个月——来发布关于易卜拉欣枪击事件的报告。它也没有告诉我们该如何理解易卜拉欣所谓的供词，或者是什么把探员带到了他的客厅，他们是否真的有任何确凿的证据把易卜拉欣或塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫与谋杀案联系起来。
In the course of reporting this story, I've reached out to the Waltham Police Department, the Middlesex District Attorney's Office, the Massachusetts State Police, the Massachusetts Attorney General, the State Attorney for Osceola and Orange Counties, the Orlando Police Department, the Department of Justice, and of course, the FBI, and none of them will comment. But I've also talked to dozens of people connected to the murders and connected to Ibragim and the Tsarnaevs, as well as to attorneys in law enforcement. And I do have a theory about what happened in Ibragim's apartment and in the months before and after. It's just a theory, but here goes.
在报道这个故事的过程中，我联系了沃尔瑟姆警察局、米德尔塞克斯地方检察官办公室、马萨诸塞州警察局、马萨诸塞州总检察长、奥西奥拉和奥兰治县州检察官、奥兰多警察局、司法部，当然还有FBI，他们都不愿置评。但我还和几十个与谋杀案有关的人、与易卜拉欣和萨纳耶夫兄弟有关的人，以及执法部门的律师谈过。我确实有一个关于易卜拉欣公寓里发生的事情以及前后的几个月里发生了什么的理论。这只是个理论，但且听我说。
As best as I can tell, the FBI showed up at Ibragim's door looking for a terrorist. He'd spoken on the phone with Tamerlan Tsarnaev in the month before the bombing, and I know a guy named John Allan who tipped off investigators. John's the owner of a mixed martial arts gym in Boston where both Tamerlan Tsarnaev and Ibragim trained. He says he was on a trip in Thailand when the bombings happened.
据我所知，FBI找上易卜拉欣的门是想找恐怖分子。他在爆炸案发生前一个月曾与塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫通电话，我知道一个叫约翰·艾伦（John Allan）的人向调查人员通风报信。约翰是波士顿一家综合格斗健身房的老板，塔梅尔兰·萨纳耶夫和易卜拉欣都在那儿训练。他说爆炸案发生时他正在泰国旅行。
Before I even got back, you know, I had a Facebook message. One of my cop students-- one of my students that's a policeman-- that has Ibragim's information. Give it to him. You should probably check this guy out.
甚至在我回来之前，你知道，我就收到了Facebook信息。我的一名警察学生——我的一名当警察的学生——有易卜拉欣的信息。把它给他。你应该检查下这个人。
John says that several times, he saw Tamerlan and Ibragim praying at the gym, which he thought was odd. Plus, he says, Ibragim just seemed kind of crazy.
约翰说，有几次他看到塔梅尔兰和易卜拉欣在健身房祷告，他觉得这很奇怪。另外，他说，易卜拉欣看起来有点疯狂。
I mean, he was definitely out there. He was definitely very Muslim. And if you were to ask me at the time if someone was capable of doing that, I would have said Ibragim not Tamerlan, you know? And I'm talking about the bombing.
我的意思是，他确实非常激进。他确实非常穆斯林。如果你当时问我是否有人有能力做那种事，我会说是易卜拉欣而不是塔梅尔兰，你知道？我说的是爆炸案。
Within a few days of this tip, FBI agents were at Ibragim's apartment. John says it never occurred to him that Ibragim could have been involved in the Waltham triple murders. He didn't mention anything like that to the police or FBI.
收到此线索几天内，FBI探员就在易卜拉欣的公寓里了。约翰说他从没想过易卜拉欣可能卷入了沃尔瑟姆三尸命案。他没向警察或FBI提到过任何类似的事。
But by the time they locked up Tatiana, about two and a half weeks later, they'd made the connection. Where that suspicion came from exactly, that Ibragim was involved in the Waltham murders, I just don't know. I ran down every path I could think of to try to find something linking Ibragim to the killings.
但在大约两周半后他们拘留塔蒂亚娜时，他们已经建立了联系。那种怀疑，即易卜拉欣卷入了沃尔瑟姆谋杀案，究竟从何而来，我实在不知道。为了找到连接易卜拉欣与命案的任何线索，我尝试了我想到的每一条路径。
I looked into some established crime rings in Waltham, but couldn't connect them to Ibragim. I tried finding evidence that he was even in the Boston area in September of 2011 when the murders happened. I pulled his driving records, talked to landlords, employers, roommates. I can place him in Boston a month before the murders and a few months after, but not in September. His wife claims he was in Atlanta with her at the time, but she has no proof.
我调查了沃尔瑟姆的一些既有犯罪团伙，但无法将他们与易卜拉欣联系起来。我尝试寻找他在2011年9月谋杀案发生时甚至身在波士顿地区的证据。我查了他的驾驶记录、咨询了房东、雇主、室友。我可以确认他在谋杀案发生前一个月和后几个月在波士顿，但9月份不行。他妻子声称他当时和她在亚特兰大，但她没有任何证据。
Not long after Ibragim was killed, law enforcement sources told The New York Times that they put together, quote, "a lot of circumstantial pieces" that they then used to pressure Ibragim into implicating himself and Tamerlan in the Waltham murders. It's possible that that's all they had, circumstantial pieces, which wouldn't go very far at trial.
易卜拉欣被杀后不久，执法部门消息人士告诉《纽约时报》，他们搜集了“大量间接证据”，然后用这些证据向易卜拉欣施压，迫使他指认自己和塔梅尔兰卷入了沃尔瑟姆谋杀案。有可能他们只有这些，间接证据，这在法庭审判中走不了多远。
So again, this is my theory. But because their evidence was thin, I think law enforcement and prosecutors needed a confession. They needed to put pressure on Ibragim to get him to crack. And in fact, a law enforcement official told The New York Times that to get Ibragim to talk about the triple murders, investigators, quote, "made him believe he's done, and the only way he could help himself is confess and lay out the details of what had happened."
所以再次声明，这是我的理论。但因为他们的证据薄弱，我认为执法部门和检察官需要一份供词。他们需要向易卜拉欣施压，让他崩溃。事实上，一名执法官员告诉《纽约时报》，为了让易卜拉欣谈论三尸命案，调查人员“让他相信他完了，唯一能帮助自己的办法就是供认并说出发生细节。”
But then the officials said that Ibragim flipped out. Which brings up the question, was the FBI shooting of Ibragim justified?
但随后官员们说易卜拉欣发狂了。这就引出了一个问题：FBI枪杀易卜拉欣合理吗？
If Ibragim became irate and aggressive and attacked the guy, I can understand why he unloaded his weapon. Ibragim wasn't going to stop.
如果易卜拉欣变得愤怒、充满攻击性并袭击了那个人，我可以理解他为什么清空弹夹。易卜拉欣是不会停下的。
This is John Allan again, the owner of the MMA gym Ibragim and Tamerlan went to. John trained Ibragim for his professional fights.
这是约翰·艾伦，易卜拉欣和塔梅尔兰去过的综合格斗健身房老板。约翰曾训练易卜拉欣参加职业比赛。
I mean, unless there was a mortal wound that ended his life right there, trust me, I mean, he would break every bone in his body to headbutt somebody.
我的意思是，除非当时有致命伤让他当场结束生命，相信我，我的意思是，他会折断自己身上的每一根骨头去头槌某人。
John Allan, of course, wasn't in the room when Ibragim was shot. But he says Ibragim was a very good fighter and had a short fuse, and there were other times Ibragim snapped and got violent. There was the incident at the hookah bar where he beat up Youness, of course. But Ibragim also got arrested for beating a guy unconscious over a parking space at a mall in Florida, and for a road rage incident in Boston.
约翰·艾伦当然在易卜拉欣被枪杀时不在房间里。但他表示，易卜拉欣是一名非常优秀的格斗选手，性子急躁，还有其他时候易卜拉欣也曾失控并变得暴力。当然，有水烟吧那起打伤尤尼斯的事件。但易卜拉欣还曾因在佛罗里达一家商场的停车位上把一个人打昏而被捕，在波士顿也发生过路怒事件。
Certain stuff just set him off. John Allan remembers he had a weird thing about one particular swear word.
有些事情就是会让他爆发。约翰·艾伦记得他对一个特定的脏话很敏感。
You know, if somebody were to say mother expletive to him, he would lose it. I mean, he would lose it. He'd be ready to fight 17 people and not care if he would win or lose, or he would just lose it. Sometimes it wouldn't even be directed at him.
你知道，如果有人对他说那种辱骂母亲的脏话，他会失去理智。我的意思是，他会失去理智。他会准备好跟17个人干架，根本不在乎输赢，或者他就是会失去理智。有时那甚至不是针对他的。
I tried to explain to him, like, listen, it's not a literal term in America. It's just a slang saying. It doesn't mean literally, you know? But there was definitely something going on with him and anger issues.
我试着向他解释，听着，这在美国不是个字面术语。这只是俚语。这不代表字面意义，你知道？但他确实有某些易怒问题。
According to the police report for Ibragim's road rage arrest, Ibragim was heard yelling at another driver, quote, "you say something about my mother, I will kill you."
根据易卜拉欣路怒被捕的警察报告，有人听到易卜拉欣对着另一名司机大喊：“你再说我母亲，我就杀了你。”
Since the FBI report hasn't come out explaining what happened that night in Ibragim's apartment, I turn to David Boeri. He's a crime and courts reporter for Boston Public Radio Station WBUR. He's covered the FBI for 30 years and has reported on the night Ibragim Todashev was shot. I wanted to know what his law enforcement sources told him about that night. David says he talked to several law enforcement sources who heard or read accounts from the people in the room.
由于FBI报告尚未解释那晚在易卜拉欣公寓里发生了什么，我转向了大卫·博伊里（David Boeri）。他是波士顿公共广播电台WBUR的法庭记者。他报道FBI已经30年了，并报道了易卜拉欣·托达舍夫被枪杀的那晚。我想知道他的执法部门消息人士告诉他关于那个晚上的什么。大卫说他与几位执法部门消息人士谈过，他们听过或读过房间里的人的描述。
Inside his apartment-- it's a very small apartment. You've been there. You saw how small it was. There are three people from Boston.
在他的公寓里——这是一个非常小的公寓。你去过那里。你看到了它有多小。房间里有三个人，来自波士顿。
The three people were an FBI agent who'd come down from Boston and two Massachusetts state troopers. I have been in that apartment when I visited Tatiana. It's one square room with wall to wall carpeting and a lofted bed. It sits by the side of a swamp. The entire back side of the house is made of shuttered glass windows. There's air conditioning, but in the muggy Orlando weather, it's not enough.
那三个人是一名从波士顿下来的FBI探员和两名马萨诸塞州警。我拜访塔蒂亚娜时曾去过那个公寓。它是一个带有墙到墙地毯和高架床的方形房间。它坐落在沼泽边上。房子的整个背面由百叶窗玻璃窗组成。有空调，但在奥兰多闷热的天气里，这根本不够。
Well, we also know from one of the people in that room, according to accounts of what he said, it was hot. It was very hot. He was sweating that night.
嗯，我们也从房间里的一个人那里知道，根据他所说内容的陈述，当时很热。非常热。那天晚上他在出汗。
David says they began questioning Ibragim about the Waltham murders. The interview started at 7:30.
大卫说他们开始审问易卜拉欣关于沃尔瑟姆谋杀案的事。审讯在7点30分开始。
In those rooms, if you've ever seen tapes of interrogations taking place-- and I have-- they are fraught with tension, accusation. They're pushing him. That's what interrogators do.
在那些房间里，如果你看过审讯录像——我看过——它们充满了紧张和指责。他们在逼迫他。这就是审讯人员所做的。
Push him. No, I don't believe that. No, I don't believe that. You're telling me this, that, whatever. It's churning up conflict and stress. And they are trained to deal in stress when they're doing interrogations to break down their suspect.
逼迫他。不，我不信。不，我不信。你告诉我的这个，那个，随便什么。它在制造冲突和压力。他们在审讯时经过训练要利用压力来瓦解嫌疑人。
At some point close to midnight, according to the accounts of one of the people in that room, Todashev said, look, I was there, but I didn't do the murders.
在午夜前后的某个时间，根据房间里某人的陈述，托达舍夫说，看，我当时在场，但我没有参与谋杀。
This, according to David's sources, was Ibragim's confession. If it's true, that means Ibragim was, at the very least, an accessory to murder. David says one of the state troopers went out of the room to make a phone call back to Massachusetts. The other two interviewers were left in the room with Ibragim as he was about to write down his confession. According to David's sources, the trooper in the room sent a text message to the FBI agent right next to him that Ibragim looked like he was going to go off.
这是根据大卫消息来源的易卜拉欣的供词。如果是真的，那就意味着易卜拉欣至少是谋杀的从犯。大卫说其中一名州警走出房间去拨打回马萨诸塞州的电话。另外两名审问者留在房间里陪着即将写下供词的易卜拉欣。根据大卫消息来源，留在房间里的警察给身边的FBI探员发了一条短信，说易卜拉欣看起来要失控了。
And it is at that point that Todashev is said to have flipped the table and gone after the FBI agent. The trooper says he never saw a human move as fast as Todashev did. The trooper also says that Todashev picked up a pipe, that he came at the trooper, and that he would have smashed his skull with the pipe if the FBI agent hadn't shot him.
就在那时，据说托达舍夫掀翻了桌子，扑向了FBI探员。警察说他从未见过人的动作像托达舍夫那样快。警察还说，托达舍夫捡起一根管子，他冲向警察，如果FBI探员没开枪打死他，他就会用管子敲碎他的头骨。
Todashev comes over the table. The FBI agent, recovering, fires three shots. Todashev went down to his knee and then got up. And then the second round of four bullets was fired by the FBI agent, and he went down and stayed down.
托达舍夫翻过桌子。FBI探员在恢复后开了三枪。托达舍夫跪倒在地，然后又站了起来。接着FBI探员开了第二轮四发子弹，他倒下后就没再起来。
From all the stories I've heard about Ibragim's temper, it seems very possible that he could have lunged or lashed out in a frustrating situation, and that an agent could have felt threatened by it. But I also want to point out that, from my reporting, it's perfectly possible Ibragim could have blown up at an agent in that situation even if he was completely innocent of the murders. His friend Khusen told TV reporters that the day of that final interview, Ibragim told him he was afraid agents were going to frame him for something.
从我听到的所有关于易卜拉欣脾气的故事来看，他完全可能在令人沮丧的情况下冲过来或发火，而探员可能对此感到威胁。但我也想指出，根据我的报道，完全可能即使易卜拉欣是谋杀案的局外人，他也会在那种情况下对探员爆发。他的朋友库森告诉电视记者，那次最终审讯的当天，易卜拉欣告诉他，他害怕探员会给他设局。
He felt. He had a bad feeling, because he felt like there was going to be setup. He felt like there was going to be setup, bad setup against him, you know what I mean?
他感觉到了。他有种不祥的预感，因为他觉得会有个套。他觉得会有个套，对他很坏的套，你知道我意思吗？
Because he felt-- he told me, like, they're making up such a crazy stuff. I don't know why they're doing it. Why are they doing it? OK, I'm answering the questions, but they're still making up some connection, some crazy stuff. I don't know why they're doing it.
因为他感觉——他告诉我，他们编造了那么多疯狂的事。我不知道他们为什么要这样做。为什么要这样做？好吧，我在回答问题，但他们仍在编造一些联系，一些疯狂的东西。我不知道他们为什么要这样做。
Five hours of intense accusations for a murder he knew he didn't commit? That could make Ibragim explode too.
对于一起他知道自己没参与的谋杀，连续五个小时的强烈指责？那也可能让易卜拉欣爆炸。
Ibrahim's wife told me that FBI agents told her that they had DNA evidence against Ibragim. But if that was the case, why didn't they arrest him? Did they not have enough evidence for an indictment?
易卜拉欣的妻子告诉我，FBI探员告诉她他们有针对易卜拉欣的DNA证据。但如果情况如此，他们为什么不逮捕他？他们没有足够的证据提起指控吗？
I believe that the night of that final interview, any evidence they had against Ibragim was thin. I believe that because they didn't arrest him, and because many people told me that the FBI kept investigating Ibragim after he was dead. And yes, the FBI might have kept interviewing people even if they had tons of evidence already, but it almost seems like they were starting an investigation into Ibragim from scratch.
我相信在那次最终审讯的那晚，他们拥有的针对易卜拉欣的任何证据都很薄弱。我相信这一点，因为他们没有逮捕他，而且许多人告诉我，FBI在易卜拉欣死后一直在调查他。是的，即使他们已经有了大量证据，FBI可能还会继续询问人们，但这几乎看起来像是在从零开始调查易卜拉欣。
Employees at MMA gyms, Ibragim's former roommate, people who worked in the hookah bar plaza, people far from the murder, they all told me the FBI came around asking very basic questions about Ibragim after his death. Lawyers at CARE, the Council on American Islamic Relations, told me in the weeks after Ibragim was killed they were getting frantic calls from Ibragim's acquaintances around the country saying the FBI was trying to talk to them.
健身房的员工、易卜拉欣的前室友、在水烟吧广场工作的人、离谋杀案很远的人，他们都告诉我，易卜拉欣死后，FBI过来问一些关于他的非常基础的问题。美国伊斯兰关系理事会（CARE）的律师告诉我，在易卜拉欣被杀后的几周里，他们接到了来自全国各地易卜拉欣熟人的疯狂电话，说FBI正试图和他们谈话。
When the FBI did manage to get Ashur into an interview room four months later, this guy who'd never been to Boston, who'd only known him Ibragim for a year, they grilled him for hours about Ibragim and the Waltham murders, murders that, allegedly, Ibragim had already confessed to being involved in.
四个月后，当FBI确实设法把阿舒尔带进审讯室时，这个从未去过波士顿、只认识易卜拉欣一年的家伙，他们盘问了他几个小时关于易卜拉欣和沃尔瑟姆谋杀案的事，而据称易卜拉欣已经供认参与了那些谋杀。
One reasonable explanation for all these interviews, and for the FBI and Massachusetts investigators to keep the murder case open, is that they think maybe there are other accomplices out there. But I believe there's still a lot about this case they don't know. We may never find out who killed those three men, or why they were killed. If Ibragim were still alive, we may have had a better chance to get to the bottom of this. But instead, the FBI and the Massachusetts State Police decided to interrogate a trained fighter with a hair trigger temper in his own overheated apartment for five hours.
关于所有这些审讯，以及FBI和马萨诸塞州调查人员保持谋杀案调查的开放状态，一种合理的解释是他们认为可能还有其他同伙在外面。但我相信关于这个案子他们仍有很多未知。我们可能永远不会知道是谁杀害了那三个人，或者他们为什么要被杀。如果易卜拉欣还活着，我们可能有更好的机会查明真相。但相反，FBI和马萨诸塞州警察决定在一个闷热的公寓里，审讯一名性子急躁的格斗选手五个小时。
Susan Zalkind. She reported a version of this story for Boston magazine this month. A link to that story, which has some interesting details and people that we could not fit into an hour long program, is at our website, thisamericanlife.org, or just Google your way to Boston magazine's website.
苏珊·扎尔金德。她本月为《波士顿》杂志报道了这个故事的一个版本。该故事的链接在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，或者通过谷歌搜索进入《波士顿》杂志网站，上面有一些我们无法塞进一小时长节目中的有趣细节和人物。
[MUSIC - MICHAEL BRETT, "I'M TAKING ALL MY SECRETS TO THE GRAVE"]
（音乐 - 迈克尔·布雷特《我将带着我所有的秘密进坟墓》）
Well, our program was produced today by Brian Reed and our senior producer, Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Sarah Koenig, [INAUDIBLE], Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager.
好的，我们的节目今天由布莱恩·里德和我们的资深制片人朱莉·斯奈德制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·富、萨拉·凯尼格、（听不清）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。
Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Allison Davis. Research help today from Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Grey, from Rob Gettis.
伊莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨运营我们的网站。 Allison Davis提供制作帮助。今天的调研协助来自米歇尔·哈里斯。音乐协助来自达米安·格雷和罗布·盖蒂斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Torey Malatia. You know, I learned this really weird thing about his mother. Oh, wait, what? What's that, Torey?
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。你知道，我了解到关于他母亲的一件很奇怪的事。哦，等等，什么？那是什么，托里？
You say something about my mother, I will kill you.
你再说我母亲，我就杀了你。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - MICHAEL BRETT, "I'M TAKING ALL MY SECRETS TO THE GRAVE"]
（音乐 - 迈克尔·布雷特《我将带着我所有的秘密进坟墓》）
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。